are those companies that say they will
help you deal with the IRS legit my
husband and I had several years of
unfiled taxes and fear that we owe the
IRS a huge amount of money can those
companies who claim that they can stop
the IRS from garnishing your wages
actually do it well I'm just wondering
why you're waiting till you get to the
point of garnishing of wages why not
just dig a Little Deeper if you're in
baby step two if you're working on
paying off your debt this is going to go
right to the top of the list this is
going to be Numero Uno nothing nothing
ahead of it we're going to contact a tax
professional and file our taxes well
yeah you got to file your taxes and tell
the IRS what you owe they're not going
to tell you what you ow you don't want
to ask the IRS anything cuz they don't
know either they're dumber than a rock